[Music]
on this wednesday night a blockade
between new brunswick and nova scotia
cleared traffic on the trans-canada gets
moving again the protesters and the
police presence
there's the delta variant and now
there's delta plus
how much more menacing is this mutation
under the microscope the likely link
between the pfizer and moderna shots
and a rare heart condition in young
people
coming back from covid to know that he
is home
is miraculous the man who defied death
and his doctors
global national with donna friesen
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin in atlantic canada where a
last-minute change to border reopening
rules reached a flash point on the
trans-canada highway
and police moved in not long ago to
intervene
for more than 17 hours protesters
blocked the highway at the new brunswick
nova scotia border
people had thought today would be the
day they could finally travel freely
across that border but
just hours before reopening nova scotia
premier ian rankin pivoted
saying travelers from new brunswick
would still have to self-isolate
if they cross into his province rankin
says the decision was made because new
brunswick has
opened up to the rest of canada in his
province is not ready to take that risk
we need a lot more second doses out i
think that it's a reasonable plan
to just wait for that week june 30th new
brunswick will be
back in the bubble is the plan and no
more self-isolation no
no testing requirements but we need that
extra week
well not long ago police moved in to
clear the blockade on the highway
they're detaining protesters who resist
our ross lord is there ross
what's happening now
well donna right now there's a long line
of rcmp officers and a line of
protesters across from them a little
while ago
the police presence here increased in
terms of the number of vehicles
after that they informed the crowd that
it was
in their words an unlawful assembly and
that they would have to leave the
highway
so the vehicles that were barricading
blockading the highway in each direction
here at the border
are gone now some of the protesters have
dispersed as well
others are still here some have been
detained those who refuse to move back
after the maudie's instructed them to do
so
so it looks like the blockade itself
at this point is over uh we don't know
yet if this is the
end to this uprising which began
because people here especially near this
border
were upset over nova scotia's new covet
19 rules
that doctor in our u-haul is not going
to work
the blockade is a surprise that followed
a surprise
protesters say they were blindsided when
nova scotia decided
people entering from new brunswick would
still be subject to vaccination and
isolation rules
while loosening restrictions for those
coming from pei and newfoundland and
labrador
we want the borders open we want the
guards gone
and we want to move freely to see
friends family visitor cottages
nova scotia premier ian rankin says his
reasoning is simple
there's more risk from new brunswick
because it allows people from anywhere
in canada to travel there freely
rankin urges patience i respect their
decision to go faster and i would just
ask for
respect for for our decision to take it
more cautiously
protesters say they've waited long
enough my children and my grandson are
in moncton 30 minutes away
and i haven't seen them since october
and
i need to see them my mental health is
not at a
good place the uprising was organized
via facebook its promoters included the
opposition mla for the nova scotia
side of the border who demanded premier
rankin ease the restrictions
and if you don't the transcanada highway
will be shut down
deciding which vehicles to let through
has at times caused friction
even between protesters
other protesters intervened along with
rcmp officers
some truckers were stranded at the
border all night protesters say they
allowed health care workers to cross
although officials at the nearby
regional hospital say five nurses and
three respiratory therapists did not
make it to work
forcing the hospital to provide
essential services only
for the atlantic provinces which have
been praised for cooperating so well
during the pandemic
this is a turnabout and not a good one
the premiers of the four provinces had a
snap meeting
to try to sort out some sort of
compromise a way to get the traffic
moving again
while finding a set of rules that they
could all agree on
donna all right ross lord on the
transcanada between nova scotia and new
brunswick tonight thanks
now to the pandemic canada still leads
the world in administering first doses
of covet 19 vaccine more than 66 percent
of canadians have received at least one
shot over 21 percent
are now fully vaccinated and today the
medical health officer for
peel region in ontario had a message for
anyone who got a dose of pfizer first
and are now being offered
moderna as a second dose his advice do
not refuse it
that's the equivalent of saying that you
won't fly with an airline because it's
not your preferred airline
that has seats often an island that is
sinking you'd rather wait
for the next available seat on your
preferred airline which could be weeks
away
dr lowe says an mrna vaccine is an mrna
vaccine and people should
take whatever they are offered first
canada is on track to have the majority
of people fully vaccinated before the
end of summer
and the pressure keeps mounting on the
federal government to set out clear
guidelines about what we can
and cannot do michael couture reports
i don't know what the the road looks
like after those two
luke ireland got his first dose of the
kovit 19 vaccine wednesday and is
already looking forward to his second
but few people at this clinic know what
fully vaccinated life
will look like but do you have an idea
of what you can do
after you get that second dose
well at the moment that's a good
question
susan lindsay's 16 year old son just got
his first dose and
everyone in the family is anxious to
hear what they can
and can't do once they have both doses
nothing is going to change that
significantly until the government
actually
mandates what you're allowed and can't
do manitoba's top doctor was even asked
if fully vaccinated people
could hug each other outdoors at a
barbecue
and while he said it should be safe dr
brent roosen admitted
there is a lack of canada-wide guidance
we're working at
sort of with with all the national
colleagues to start coming out with
specific advice on those scenarios the
u.s centers for disease
control had that kind of specific advice
41 days ago
saying fully vaccinated people can go
into each other's homes
without a mask some doctors worry a lack
of rules for fully vaccinated canadians
could lead to more problems
if we don't have guidance there'll be a
large number of people who are forging
their own rules or doing their own way
and it might not be safe and this is why
it's important for us to
give give guidance for for the
population canada's
top doctor says the delta variant and
local case counts mean
it's not a black and white decision we
would like to
enable people to take themselves
through that kind of risk assessment
while respecting local public health
requirements this epidemiologist says
it's tough to strike that balance
this is a struggle between our liberal
democratic
individualistic perspectives and the
need to
to enact communal good and the two of
intention for the last 15 months
and that is likely to continue until
more people are vaccinated
and more restrictions are removed
michael couture global news ottawa
the european union wants its member
nations to speed up vaccination efforts
its center for disease prevention and
control warns the delta variant is on
track to account for 90 percent of all
covert 19 cases in europe by the end of
august
it has already spread to 23 european
countries
studies show two vaccine doses offer the
best protection but only about 29
percent of eu residents are
fully vaccinated you have heard a lot
about the delta variant and now there's
some evidence emerging about
delta plus a mutation that has been
declared a variant of concern in
india scientists are keeping a close eye
on it because there is some
limited evidence that it could be even
more transmissible than the original
delta variant redmond shannon explains
what we know and don't know
about it this himalayan trek is part of
india's
ramped up vaccine program millions of
shots
now administered every day as it
continues to struggle with infections
believed to be driven by the delta
variant and now india's health ministry
is telling state governments it has
found
40 cases of a delta mutation delta plus
india is classifying it as a variant of
concern possibly more transmissible
and more resistant to a particular
covid19 treatment
the index cases of these delta
plus variant should be monitored very
closely
the delta plus variant is a mutation of
the spy protein on the virus called
k417n it was also found on the beta and
gamma variants which first appeared in
south africa and brazil
the delta plus mutation was first
reported by public health authorities
here in
england earlier this month the first
known case
was taken from a sample in india in
april at the start of its brutal
second wave many experts say it's too
early to say if
this mutation is a greater threat than
delta alone
it's not always like two plus two is
four
in case of viruses it's not like that
virologist levin
abrahamian says it's encouraging that
this mutation does not appear to have
dominated
the original we still don't have so many
in europe and
in the united states and canada so that
makes me
think that is not so bad as delta by
itself
or it's not at least
worse than than delta experts say many
more cases need to be analyzed before we
know if it affects transmissibility
disease severity treatments or vaccine
effectiveness
i would be you know really surprised if
in the next week a couple of weeks
we don't get more information fewer than
200 cases have been identified outside
of india
including at least one in canada redmond
shannon global news
london there's more information tonight
on reports of heart
inflammation among young people who have
had the pfizer or moderna mrna vaccines
the american centers for disease control
and prevention has been
investigating for months and today said
there is a likely link
though cases are very rare the
conditions are known as myocarditis and
inflammation of the heart muscle
and pericarditis which is an
inflammation of the layers of tissue
surrounding the heart
the cdc says early data shows the
conditions are most common in people age
12 to 29 mostly among young men and
adolescent boys after the second dose of
an mrna vaccine
some incidents have also been reported
after the first dose
more than 1200 cases have been
identified in the u.s
that works out to a rate of 12.6 cases
per 1 million second doses
most cases were mild with symptoms like
fatigue
chest pain and disturbances in heart
rhythm that quickly cleared up
the cdc says the benefits of
immunization far outweigh the risks of
these
rare side effects and that heart
inflammation can also
occur when young people get covid19
extreme heat and dry conditions are
already challenging firefighting crews
in alberta
a wildfire west of edmonton is out of
control and people in a nearby town had
to flee their homes
temperatures in alberta and b.c are
forecast to break records in the days
ahead
lauren pullen reports on the fires
raging now and the fears
of what's to come fierce winds
fanning suffocating smoke and flames
burning right outside their back door
well it was scary george and norma had
mere minutes to grab whatever they could
and get out the next thing we know a
peace officer drove in lights flashing
said you guys have to leave more than
two dozen families were forced to flee
the flames of an out of control wildfire
that sparked an hour west of edmonton
tuesday
the 180 hectare fire is threatening
homes but luckily
everyone who's fled them is safe people
are tense
you know with the dry weather we're
having right now and
people are nervous that anxiety is only
increasing as canada's western provinces
dry out
and heat up with a major heat dome set
to descend upon b.c
packing a record-breaking punch we could
be breaking daytime high records
but also all-time records for the entire
month of june
the bc interior is already seeing
scorching hot temperatures
days from now it's expected they will
climb well into the 40s
and around vancouver and the bc lower
mainland we are seeing a rapid drawing
of the forest right now and that is
obviously going to be a concern
that punishing weather is expected to
move into alberta in the coming days
we're in for a quite a heat wave that's
going to impact most of the province so
we're expecting
fire danger to increase in the upcoming
days
providing little relief in the wildfire
fight but crews are confident they're
ready for whatever comes with more
resources available
if and when they're needed still for now
these homeowners can only wait
and worry we're just praying that
nothing happens while crews throw all
their efforts at getting the fires under
control
lauren pullen global news calgary
the fight to free britney spears
she can't even buy star but she can't
even drive her own car
coming up fans unite as the pop star
tells a courtroom she wants her life
back
plus the sudden death of an antivirus
software pioneer
we're here to give support to brittany
we want her to use her voice to end this
conservative once and for all
the rules are just ridiculous changes
need to be made and i'm here fighting
for my girl
britney spears supporters were outside
of los angeles courthouse as the pop
star testified she is traumatized and
wants her life back
it's her first public testimony about
the 13-year conservatorship that she's
been living under
she said her father jamie spears should
not be in control of her life and that
she feels enslaved by him she told court
i've lied and told the world i'm okay
and i'm happy it's a lie
i've been in denial i'm in shock i am
traumatized
all i want is to own my money and for
this to end
her father was appointed a
co-conservator after his daughter went
through a mental health crisis in 2008.
spears told court that control extends
to her body that she's not allowed to
have more children get married or even
remove her iud
her legal team says today was about
putting spears wishes into the public
record
the next steps will be helping her gain
more control
over her life
john mcafee the entrepreneur who created
antivirus software
has been found dead in a jail cell in
barcelona the catalan justice department
says prison medics tried to resuscitate
him and that
everything indicates mcafee took his own
life a spanish court had just
authorized his extradition to the u.s
where the 75 year old was charged with
tax evasion
mcafee developed the first commercial
anti-virus software and sold his stake
in the company for more than seven
billion dollars
he was arrested in spain last october
trying to board a flight to turkey
accused of failing to file tax returns
for four years
despite earning millions doing
consulting work
getting sticky with pictures the drama
around baseball's attempt to get a grip
on cheating
just ahead
a sticky situation gripping major league
baseball is causing
quite the stir they've increased
scrutiny for pitchers
as far as sticky substances on their
person
umpires are now checking pictures for
any hidden sticky foreign substances
that could provide a competitive edge by
giving them a better grip
on the baseball he was a little bit
heated there
after the performances he's immediately
thrown off
the belt the glove the hat on
there yeah the pitchers aren't loving it
it's led to some awkward scenes on the
field the league says
pitchers found using foreign substances
will be ejected from the game and
automatically suspended
beating the odds next won covet 19
survivors remarkable story
since the first days of the pandemic
healthcare professionals have
seen it all too often the sickest of
covet 19 patients
could not be saved this next story
though is about a man who was an
exception
he was one of the most critically ill
coveted patients admitted to an ontario
hospital his family was told to prepare
for the worst
as mike derlay reports he surprised
everyone including
his doctors
months after collapsing in his driveway
the odds were stacked against jaime
vargas taking a leisurely stroll with
his wife
ever again how it all played out is
still a blur
he remembers snippets the ambulance and
x-ray machine
and the doctor telling him covet
positive the day he came to the hospital
on march
24th he was the sickest person we
probably ever had in our emergency
department who ended up surviving
the 53 year old was put into an induced
coma almost right away
his oxygen levels were so low he had to
be intubated which led to pneumonia and
eventually collapsed lungs
it was only when he awoke 50 days later
that he learned covet protocols had
prevented his wife jolan december
from seeing him in person it was hard
like the day she told me what
when when i was better and she told me
what
what was said and what was going on like
it was hard hard
yeah and when doctors told you lawn she
needed to say goodbye to jamie
she did the unthinkable and flat out
refused
they told me yes i said no they're like
i'm of course this the wife who
i mean i believe in positive thinking so
i'm like it's not going to happen it's
not going to happen it's not going to
happen it's not going to happen
refuse to accept that it's a possibility
that this could happen
jamie is now focused on getting his
strength back
and while he's no longer in hospital
he's not far from the thoughts of those
who cared for him
kovid19 has left so many in healthcare
feeling drained and deflated jaime's
story
is something of a booster shot to know
that he actually
is home is miraculous
i think to us for this covet survivor
the miracle is a renewed positivity in
life
and another walk with yoland mike
drolite global news toronto
and that's global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your candidate is a couple of
moose exploring calgary's mackenzie lake
one took a dip in the lake and and why
not really
the place belongs to them besides
snacking on some gardens
residents say the wild visitors were
well behaved
love to jump in that lake myself thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you